hi
i'm sean law the creator and core
developer of stumpy
you can follow me on twitter at
shawnmylaw and you can also follow the
development of stumpy at stumpy
underscore dev
i'm super excited to be here today to
tell you about modern time series
analysis with stumpy
and help you take your time series
analysis skills to the next level
first and foremost i'd like to say thank
you to all the pi data
global organizers as well as volunteers
for putting on such a great conference
i'd also like to acknowledge my employer
td ameritrade for giving me the
opportunity to speak here today
at td ameritrade i work in a research
and development group called the
exploration lab
there i am a senior applied research
scientist and lead data scientist
so what's the problem we're talking
about time series data analysis here
and we've all been there where maybe you
have a collaborator maybe your boss or a
manager
let's say here's some time series data
now perform some magic dr big fancy
pants
and if you're lucky enough and the data
set is small maybe with 10 data points
you might be able to visualize it and
observe an increasing trend
maybe it's 100 data points and it's
still manageable you can see it goes up
maybe it looks bi-modal
you can compute some statistics from it
now once we get to about a thousand data
points
we might see that there is a periodic
trend or things happening or some
seasonality
and once we go beyond this to about 10
000 data points or more
it becomes a lot more challenging to
visualize if i were to ask you
can you spot anything interesting from
this time series data
any patterns any anomalies any outliers
the point here is that it's very very
hard to see now i want you to keep this
picture in mind
because once we get to the live demo
we'll revisit this and we'll use stumpy
to analyze this data
and i don't know about you but when i
look at the left-hand side of this plot
and then i shift my eyes look at the
right hand side i've already forgotten
what i've looked at in the first place
and usually after that i just feel this
overwhelming sense of dread
and i just hope that there's some magic
spell that i can cast to sort of wish it
all away
or at least tell me where i should focus
my attention on
and that's why we're here today now here
are some of those common magic spells we
talked about visualizing the data but
once it gets large it
becomes uh untenable now you can also
reach our good friend statistics we
might plot
mean median modes look at other global
statistics like the max and min
but very rarely when we're looking at
time series data are we interested in
single point statistics
we're really interested in context maybe
sequences along the way
you can also build an auto-regressive
model but this also makes a key
assumption that there is something
repetitive about your data
and you can also reach for anomaly
detection but what does
an anomaly look like in a time series
right and also if you
see it once and then a second time is it
still an anomaly
so defining what you mean by anomaly
really matters and it's really hard
you can also perform forecasting on your
time series data
maybe using facebook profit or some sort
of additive building some sort of
additive model
you can also build machine learning
model whether it's a linear logistic
regression
or a gradient boosted trees
but now you might have to think about
how do you interpret results
or the model itself you can also reach
for unsupervised learning uh methods
such as clustering where you're
clustering your time
series but even that's pretty hard
and of course there's dynamic time
warping so if you have data sets
that are of different lengths how might
you compress and stretch them out
in order to compare them and of course
in the age of artificial intelligence
you can't forget about deep learning
everybody's sort of favorite hammer
looking for nail to hit
and now you need a ton of data and also
a lot of compute power
in order to process this and the point
here isn't that
to point out all the pros and cons of
all these different methods the point
here is to remember that there's no
silver bullet
and there's no free lunch every method
that you reach for comes with some sort
of compromise
each method is good at different things
and hopefully what you'll take home
today is that even a method like stumpy
can be used in addition to all these
other methods
right so it's another tool to add to
your tool belt but hopefully
uh you can iterate quickly and hopefully
get to your insights quicker too
so let's start with an illustrative
example here's a time series
of length 13. anything interesting about
this
you might notice that it's bounded
between 0 and 15
are there any repeating patterns what if
we plotted it
you can see that there's some highs and
some lows
let's start off with a definition a
subsequence and you're going to hear me
say this word
many many times so a subsequence is
simply a part
or section of the full time series so
for instance
this could be a subsequence this could
be a subsequence of length three
this could be a subsequence of length
eight so
what's the goal we're thinking about uh
time series analysis
and if you think back to some of the
magic spells that we just covered
many of those approaches make a key
assumption that there is some sort of
conserved behavior
or perhaps a pattern that repeats itself
and so
our goal really should be to think about
if a behavior is conserved
in your time series there must have been
a reason why i was conserved
and teasing out these reasons and these
causes is often very very useful
okay and so that should be our goal and
we can digest this
and summarize this uh by asking two
questions of all of our time series data
number one do any conserved behaviors
exist in my time series data or do any
patterns exist
and if there if there are conserved
behaviors what are they
and where are they to answer these
questions i like to use occam's razor
which states that simpler solutions are
more likely to be correct
than complex ones so we're favoring
simplicity over complexity
and so we should ask ourselves what's
the most simple and intuitive
intuitive approach that we can take to
analyze our time series data
and some of the qualities that our
approach should have is that it needs to
be easy to interpret
so if you come back three months later
you don't have to perform any mental
gymnastics to interpret your data
it also needs to be user and data
agnostic so anybody can use it
and hopefully be able to apply to any
time series
uh also our approach should have
required no prior knowledge
so thinking about machine learning where
oftentimes you have to train the model
first
before you can perform a prediction uh
in our particular case we want an
approach where
we don't have to train and predict we
just analyze
up front and last but not least we want
our approach to be parameter free
or essentially be parameter free and if
we had we
if we were forced to choose a parameter
that parameter would be intuitive and
obvious
and that that parameter is not so
sensitive to the method that we choose
so for instance in time series analysis
one of these parameters might be the
subsequence length
so we call it m and so in this
particular in this particular case
there's a subsequence of length four now
that we've established this
we can ask ourselves how might we
compare subsequences so how about we
compare this
green subsequence to this blue one on
the right
now one of the most obvious ways to do
this is to compute something called the
euclidean distance
and it's simply the straight line
distance between two points
so what does this mean in practice so if
we take these two subsequences
no you know what let's shorten them just
to start off
with a simple example we have our
subsequence on the left
on the left called x it's got two points
x and y
and our subsequence on the right called
y with also two points
y one and y two we can plot them x over
here
y over here and we know that the
euclidean distance is just a straight
straight line distance between them
let's just call it h for simplicity
and intuitively we know how to compute h
once we draw a right angle triangle
label the sides we actually know that
h squared is equal to a squared plus b
squared and hopefully you'll recognize
this is nothing but our
good friend pythagorean theorem and once
we plug
in our numbers we actually find that
h is actually equal to square root of
two so the distance between these two
subsequences
root two extending this to our original
example where subsequent sequences were
of length four
we see that we have an x three term and
a y three term
and now we update our pythagorean
theorem
with a c squared term and we also have
an x square and y four term
then we now have a d squared term that's
covering that
so as you increase the length of your
subsequences you might have an e squared
term and an f squared term and so on and
so forth
so this is extensible and we can plug in
our numbers and find that the distance
between these two subsequences is square
root of 67. and that's it
but this is the case where somebody
gives you
both both of the subsequences and you
can compare them
but what if we wanted to take the green
subsequence and say is this
subsequence conserved across our time
series then what we can do is
compute pairwise euclidean distances to
do that we'll repeat our time series
and we'll create a blue subsequence that
we'll compare against
and then we'll record the distance
between the green subsequence and the
blue subsequence
in this vector down below so in this
particular case the green and blue
subsequences are identical
so the distance is zero and i'll slide
that blue subsequence over compute the
distance
and i'll continue doing this all the way
until i run out of subsequences to
compare
with the green one and what we end up
with is something called a distance
profile
pretty straightforward now if we were to
ask is that green subsequence conserved
anywhere
in this time series what we do is we
look at our distance profile
and look for the smallest value in this
particular case the smallest value
is zero and it's showing that
the closest one is the self match or
often called the
trivial match now we're this is pretty
obvious
we're not that interested in this one so
we often just ignore this one
and we slide across again looking for
the next closest match
and that happens to be this blue
subsequence here and the green and the
blue cell sequence
have a distance of 6.9 away nothing else
is closer
now we don't only have to do this with
the green subsequence that we're showing
here
we can actually just keep sliding that
green subsequence across i'm computing
all of the possible pairwise euclidean
distances
and all of these distance profiles and
once we stack them on top of each other
remove the unnecessary parts what we end
up with is a distance matrix
and this is an exact uh distance matrix
there are no false positives we compute
all the distances and it's pretty
intuitive
and so what's the most simple intuitive
approach i'd say that this distance
matrix approach is
pretty straightforward it's easy to
interpret and it checks all of
the boxes in terms of all the key
qualities that we're looking for
but wait there's got to be a catch it
feels too simple
we should really be asking ourselves is
the solution scalable
and so if we were to ask how about we
perform a brute force calculation to
compute this distance matrix
so let's start with some python code so
we define our
time series up above with a length of 13
and a subsequence length of 4 and our
time series is also down at the bottom
for illustration purposes and to compute
the distance matrix it actually just
requires six lines of python
code i don't know focus your attention
on these three for loops
the first for eye loop corresponds to
sliding this green subsequence across
this 4j loop focuses on
sliding the blue subsequence across as
well and the 4k loop is for computing
your euclidean distance
and if you're thinking about well what
is the computational complexity
it actually takes o of n squared by m
time to compute this distance matrix
and also to store this in memory it
would take o n square time
to put this into perspective here's the
back of the envelope calculation
imagine you have an iot sensor that was
collecting data for five years
365 days a year 44 hours a day
60 minutes every hour 20 times every
minute that means that for
five years straight every three seconds
your sensor would be collecting a data
point
this would result in just over 50
million data points in your time series
data
and if you were to use your brute force
method to compute the distance matrix
it would take roughly 4.4 years to
compute and over 11 petabytes of memory
to store and so if we ask ourselves is
the solution scalable
sadly it is not and it kind of explains
why all these methods are so popular
people are
still using it to this day it's because
this distant matrix while it's intuitive
and simple
it just wasn't scalable that is until
today
so back in the december of 2016 the
researchers at the university of
california riverside under iman keogh's
group
as well as at the university of new
mexico under abdullah malin's group
published a series of back-to-back
papers describing something called a
matrix profile
and really what a matrix profile is is a
vector that stores the distance between
each subsequence within a time series
and its nearest neighbor believe it or
not you actually know what this means
going back to our illustrative example
starting with the distance matrix
a matrix profile is simply taking the
nearest neighbors
to each subsequence which is exactly
where those green boxes are
and pull them pulling them out and only
storing these
so this is your matrix profile now you
still have to compute
all of the distances just so that you're
avoiding any false positives or false
negatives
but really the good thing here is that
this is now stored in
of n space and these academic
researchers later went on to claim that
you can actually compute this full
distance matrix
and o of n squared time and using this
matrix profile you're actually able to
answer the two key questions that we
posed at the beginning
so how might we use our matrix profile
so the first thing that we do is going
back to our illustrative example
is we might annotate our time series
using the matrix profile
and we might even plot it just to look
at it and you might observe that there
are some
high points and some low points in our
matrix profile
right but to interpret this uh let's say
for this particular green
subsequence over here what this is
telling you is that its nearest neighbor
is located uh at 6.9 units away
we don't know where it is along the time
series but it's nearest number 6.9 units
away
uh this particular subsequence has a
near stable that's a little bit closer
at 1.1.4 units of work
and all the way at the very end this
subsequence it's near its neighbor is at
a distance of 6.2 away
and what we might now do is ask the
question are there any conserved
behaviors in our time series
to do that we just simply have to look
at our matrix profile
and identify the minima whether it's a
global mina or the
local minima in this particular case we
find that the global mina
minima are shown here and the one on the
left corresponds to this subsequence and
the one on the right corresponds to the
blue subsequence
and these you can understand why these
are a a
a particularly conserved sequence
because the first
data points are both ones the next one
three and two are very close
the third one they're both two and the
last one nine and ten are also very very
close
and this global minima is often referred
to as a motif
or a potential pattern conserved pattern
and using the same approach you can
identify other conserved patterns as
well
now there's another definition which is
the matrix profile index and that's the
index location
of the nearest neighbor for a given
subsequence so
for the subsequence shown in green its
nearest neighbor
is actually shown on the right but
one thing i want to point out is this
index up at the very top there's a zero
base index just for reference so the
subsequence on the left
its nearest neighbor is located at index
a the subsequence on the right
its nearest neighbor is located index
one in fact all the subsequences
have a nearest neighbor shown at the
indices down below
so to drive from this point this
particular subsequence
has a nearest neighbor that is a
distance of 6.2 away
and is located at index 2 with the same
length
and that it's this subsequence over here
another thing we can do with the matrix
profile
is identify potential anomalies to do
this you look for
maximum along your matrix profile and
that happens to be
this value here this is the biggest
number along our matrix profile and that
corresponds to
this subsequence here and this is a
potential anomaly or in time series
balance
this is known as a discord and there are
many many other things
that you can do with matrix profiles but
we'll cover them
in our documentation now we discuss how
the brute force method takes both
n squared by m time these academic
researchers
published their first paper uh detailing
an algorithm called stamp which uses
fast forward transforms and convolution
to reduce that competition time down
they then published a follow-up paper
uh called using an algorithm called
stomp which further takes that time down
to o
n squared and then they ported that
algorithm over to
gpu hardware and just show that uh
for a time series of length 100 million
which is double the
uh the number of data points that we
showed for that brute force uh
calculation
using the gpu stomp algorithm they were
able to compute
a exact matrix profile in just over 12
days
and this is among you one of the
original researchers and he states that
given the matrix profile
most time series data binding problems
are trivial to or easy to solve
in just a few lines of code and the
later we went on to say that these are
the best ideas in time series data
mining in the last two decades
and anybody who says this in my opinion
must be a real gangster
but of course extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
and this was stated by the late carl
sagan and this is
brings us to stumpy and really stumpy
was developed to validate a lot of these
claims to see if you can really compute
these matrix
profiles efficiently and quickly
and so stumpy is a powerful and scalable
python library that efficiently computes
the matrix profile
so that you don't have to reinvent the
wheel and then once you have this matrix
profile
you can use it for a variety of times
your data mining tasks
somebody has been around for just over a
year with over 50 000 downloads and
installs
and over 1500 github stars so a lot of
growth and a lot of support from the
community
we're version 1.5 and you can conduct
and pivot install it using the conform
channel and we have minimal dependencies
assuming that you're
using a modern python we use numpy scipy
number
and parallelized across
all of the cores on a given server and
if you just so happen to have a dash
cluster available to you
you can actually pass in that das client
or scheduler
to stumpy and it will distribute that
computation across
multiple servers to give you an idea
remember that a 100 million data point
sample
computing the matrix profile in just 12
days
we actually were able to compute the
same matrix profile using 250
256 cpus across 32 servers
in just under 10 days so i'm not saying
that cpus are faster than gpus
but certainly that stumpy can scale very
very well we call our version of the
uh algorithm stump it's a player on
words
the us pays homage to numba and numpy
and the distributed version the ending
in ed
is called stomped we also have a gpu
version
called gpu stump that is highly
performant that scales to larger data
sense
and if you ask us is the solution
scalable we'd say a resounding yes
and to use stumpy it's pretty
straightforward you have your time
series ts
and your subsequence length m you call
stumpy by saying stumpy.stump
pass it your time series and your
subsequence length and you're done
and if you have a larger data set you
can actually use the gpu version
which is the same essential api and the
only difference is just four letters
in addition to stump and gpu stump we
also support
uh multi-dimensional matrix profiles
using m stump or m stump for the
distributed version
you can also compute an approximate
matrix profile
maybe using one percent of the
computational time using our scrump
implementation
and last but not least if you have
streaming data and you want to update
your matrix profile as new data points
commanding coming in
you can also leverage our stumpy or
incremental stump version
so why should you use stumpy a couple of
really important reasons
first stump is super user friendly it's
developed for data scientists by data
scientist
and also stumpy is uh very interpretable
if you understand pythagorean theorem
you killed any distance
you've got this but more importantly
stumpy is fast and scalable so we have
multi-cpu and multi-gpu support
out of the box without any additional
dependencies and something is highly
reliable with a 100 code coverage always
and it also is highly complementary and
it brings us to the point of when should
you use thumpy
stuffing can be used in combination with
any of these methods that we as we
mentioned before
and it's highly complementary but the
point here is to remind you that there
is no silver bullet
and there's no free lunch you should
really use all these methods or as many
of these methods as possible
but the great thing about stumpy is that
it is now a scalable
and performance solution that you can
reach for immediately
so we're going to change gears now and
move towards a live demo
[Music]
so in this demo i want to draw your
attention to this raw time series up at
the very top
you might recognize this time series as
being the same time series that we
showed and discussed
at the beginning of our talk now
as you're focusing your attention on
this time series do you spot anything
interesting
are there any insights that jump right
out at you
perhaps you can spot maybe that there's
a pattern that repeats itself
maybe not or are there any anomalies or
outliers
that speak to you what if i showed you
what you were looking for
now this particular pattern or the
subsequence shown in green here
actually repeats itself one time
somewhere along the time series
and i've blown it up here and zoomed in
on it just so you can see all of the
finer detail
now as you go hunting across this time
series can you spot where it's near
neighbor is located
so not to belabor the point but its
nearest neighbor is actually located
all the way to the far right shown in
the great subsequence there
and i've actually plotted the gray line
down below here
so you can see that they're a pretty
close match but not exactly
the same and in fact their distance is
uh
5.5 units away from each other so it's
not zero
because they're not identical and it's a
5.5 because there's some differences
over here some differences over here
but for all intensive purposes you'd
agree that the
green subsequence matches the gray one
and to the astute observer you might
have noticed that below our time series
i've also plotted the matrix profile
and so what you might have observed is
that in our matrix profile the global
minima is located over here
and also all over here and this actually
corresponds
to a motif so these the green
subsequence and the gray subsequence
correspond to the motif or conserve
pattern or conserve behavior
but what's really nice about our matrix
profile is not only do we get
these global these global motifs but we
actually get the nearest neighbor for
every single subsequence
along our time series so when i press
play
the green's reference subsequence will
slide from left to right
and you'll observe that the gray
subsequence will change
and update in response to the changing
green subsequence
that's pretty cool right another thing
that i want to point your attention to
is
for every green subsequence its nearest
neighbor can occur
not only to the left but it can also
occur to the right
so this means that your nearest neighbor
can happen in the future
or in the past and in time series
parlance when it occurs on the left
that's called the left matrix profile
and when it happens on the right that's
simply referred to as the right matrix
profile
and generally we're uh most interested
in the global
matrix profile value now another
interesting thing that we can do here is
not to only look at the
minimal minima along our matrix profile
but we can also look for anomalies
by investigating the peaks so in this
particular case
this green subsequence again blown up
and the bottom here
has the largest matrix profile value
that means that its nearest neighbor
is it has a distance of 23.5 away
no other subsequence along this time
series has it nearest neighbor that
that's far
that is that far away and its nearest
neighbor is now overlaid with it here
and you can see that there's a lot of
differences a lot of deviation from this
green subsequence
right and so this is a discord or a
potential
but anomaly want to remind everybody
that in the case of a pattern or anomaly
i'm telling you what you're you should
be expecting and looking for
but if you think back to our original uh
process of analyzing a time series
usually what you get is just this raw
time series up above
and hopefully you can understand now
that you can leverage
the matrix profile to tell you where you
should start looking first
so you would start with this time series
you would feed into stumpy
and compute your matrix profile and then
by simply exploring the minima
it tells you where your conserved
subsequences are
and by exploring the maxima you will
identify where the anomalies are as well
but also you get all the information
in between and this is really just
scratching the surface
in addition to computing the matrix
profile for a single time series
you can actually use stumpy to compare
two different time series
times years a and time series b and
that's often referred to as
an a b joint in the literature so what
this means is
when you take time series a you're
asking if
for every single subsequence within time
series a
what is its nearest neighbor in time
series b
or to put it differently you're asking
are there conserved behaviors
in time series a that can be found in
time series b
and that can be done using stumpy
another useful resource
is our documentation in our readme you
can find
short code snippets that will help you
get up and running really quickly
the installation guide outlines how you
will conda or pip install stumpy
additionally the stumpy api outlines
several useful functions that you might
use to compute matrix profiles
or to take that matrix profile and
extract other insights from it as well
but not least are our tutorials these
tutorials provide
very detailed code snippets as well as
plots and figures
that reproduce examples from published
work so we encourage you
to dive into these tutorials and learn
more about the many different things
that you can do with stumpy
so coming back i know we've discussed a
lot of different things
uh first and foremost we've talked about
motif and discord discovery so looking
for patterns and anomalies
we've also talked about how you can use
m stump for multi-dimensional matrix
profiles
so if you have multiple sensors
collecting let's say
humidity temperature and pressure all at
the same time you can analyze
which of those time series are important
you can also do something
uh called time series chains which is
related to uh
forecasting and also semantic
segmentation
uh sometimes known as let's say change
point detection where you can detect
whether there is a regime change within
your time series uh matrix profiles and
their indices are great as inputs to
machine learning
features you can also compare and
cluster time series using something
called
mp dips and many many other things can
be done
using matrix profiles and using the
stumpy package
final calls to action we'd love to look
for new contributors especially if
you're a
minority in technology we'd love to work
with you uh also we asked you to
communicate tell all your friends and
colleagues about something
and finally consume and use stumpy it'd
make me
really happy just putting up some links
here
uh if you're looking for stumpy and your
favorite search engine search for python
stumpy
uh all of our very verbose and
informative informative tutorials can be
found in the link
shown there uh the live demo that we
showed earlier can be found in the demo
link
also we have a wonderful uh uh google
see how you can leverage the google code
lab
um all the code is open source and on
github and as well we have wonderful
documentation
that you should check out and last but
not least thank you for taking the time
to learn more about stumpy and stay safe
out there bye